Kitagawa: One tip I have
is to use
and look
into the event preview.
So by registering
a event preview,
you're able to register
a global listener
for all events that
are occurring in the browser.
This, um--events such as
mouse movements,
um, various mouse clicks,
left/right mouse button,
um, and scroll wheel events.
Regardless of which widget
is in focus,
you're able to see
and register those events,
and then be able
to take action on it.
So this is a way
that you could implement,
like, a global key listener
or something like that.
So if you wanted to have
an application--
that control-S or something
does something--saves--
you're able
to do it using that.